the Southern Baptist convention a center
of conservative and fundamentalist
religious thought in America for a long
long time is holding on to its
long-standing belief that only men
should lead its churches there had been
some pushback but yesterday the
convention rejected the appeals of two
churches that were expelled kicked out
because they have female pastors the SBC
faces a series of crises not just this
one including sexual abuse claims
leadership fights and declining
membership Janet Chamberlain has more
now from the Southern Baptist convention
in New Orleans
on the question of Saddleback Church
9437 votes in favor the vote to uphold
the ban on churches with female pastors
wasn't close and Saddleback Church is
not in Friendly cooperation with the
Southern Baptist convention delegates
upheld the February expulsions of the
Saddleback mega church in Lake Forest
California
and the smaller Fern Creek Baptist
Church in Louisville Kentucky all
because they employed female pastors
amen there has never been a moment in
the history of the Southern Baptist
convention that the Southern Baptist
convention was supportive of the idea
that women could occupy the office of
Pastor Elder and overseer it's just that
I think we've had hope that people who
had come to a different conclusion from
us
would rethink that this is a sad day for
southern Baptists let us pray someone
who didn't rethink it Pastor Linda Burns
Popham she has served as the lead pastor
at Fern Creek for 30 years she'll keep
serving independent of the Southern
Baptist convention
what does this say to the millions of
women
in the churches it says to those women
you are not valued
you cannot be called of God
and we don't want you Southern Baptists
need us more than we need them
I mean they're losing a friend we don't
want you anymore they're losing a family
member the Southern Baptist convention
statement of faith last amended in 2000
says the office of Pastor is limited to
men as qualified by scripture in a
separate vote Wednesday SBC delegates
went further they voted in favor of an
amendment broadly Banning women from any
pastoral titles we should leave no room
for our daughters and granddaughters and
the generations ahead to have confusion
on where the sbcc stands history will
prove us wrong again if we adopt this
motion the church has recently been
embroiled in Scandal including a
bombshell report last year alleging its
Executives hushed up hundreds of
allegations of sexual abuse it all comes
as the church is facing steep membership
declines nearly 460 000 members lost
last year the largest drop in more than
a century saddleback's retired pastor
and founder Rick Warren says membership
will continue to drop without
significant change 17 years of decline
year after year after year is not a
glitch
and the loss of a half a million members
in a single year cannot be ignored for
those like Pastor Barnes poplum looking
to the future is the only way forward
even outside of the SBC we will continue
to be a church we will continue to move
forward and as The Pianist texted me
earlier today or yesterday we are bound
for greater things and that's what we
believe for CBS mornings I'm Janet
shamlian in New Orleans
one of my closest friends in college
with the southern baptist and he didn't
use curse words it's a unclean language
it's prohibited in in that Faith uh I
bet a lot of Southern Baptists though
wanted to use curse words after that
result because they're concerned about
the future of the movement of course we
understand that some are traditionalists
but I have known many women who are the
spiritual anchors in their home and have
led so I don't see why they can't lead
churches